actor jeff bridges is a bonafide legend
in the entertainment industry with more
than 90 acting credits dating back to
1951 while he's perhaps best known for
playing the dude in the big lebowski
he's continued working throughout the
last decade or so in a slew of critical
and commercial hits including true grit
bad times at the el royale and the best
oscar win for crazy heart he received
his first oscar nomination way back in
1971 for the last picture show he lost
best supporting actor to follow castmate
ben johnson in october of 2020 the
well-respected actor revealed on twitter
that he was diagnosed with lymphoma he
wrote to his fans although it is a
serious disease i feel fortunate that i
have a great team of doctors and the
prognosis is good i'm starting treatment
and will keep you posted on my recovery
he kept his followers in the loop as
promised and shared a photo of himself
on instagram while receiving treatment
that same month in january 2021 bridges
shared great news to his website where
he revealed that his tumor had shrunk in
size dramatically this past march in a
separate website post the big lebowski
star told his fans that he contracted
the coronavirus and had to spend a
significant amount of time in the icu he
said my dance with kovid makes my cancer
look like a piece of cake fortunately
things are looking up again as he's
given his fans his best health update
yet on september 13th jeff bridges
shared a new post to his website where
he revealed some stellar news he wrote
my cancer is in remission the 9 by 12
mass has shrunk down to the size of a
marble my co-vid is in the rear view
mirror covered kicked my pretty good but
i'm double vaccinated and feeling much
better now i heard that the vaccine can
help folks with long haulers maybe
that's the cause of my quick improvement
bridges said he was able to walk his
daughter down the aisle at her recent
wedding without oxygen assistance
something he needed just to walk period
the two were even able to share a
wedding dance together without bridges
needing oxygen to do so he accompanied
the web pose with a video to confirm he
still has some moves on the dance floor
the actor also promoted his upcoming tv
series the old man and included a sneak
peek trailer in his post he was in the
midst of filming in 2020 but the studio
had to suspend production in march of
that year because well you know why
deadline reports that it'll be his first
return to television in 50 years based
on a thomas perry novel of the same name
the series follows retired cia officer
dan chase played by bridges who finds
himself in the crosshairs of an assassin
the old man is for a projected 2022
release date filming has started back up
for the show already so that release
date seems to be on track to remain for
2022
other people shared their stories of how
bridges helped get them through their
own illnesses one fan wrote your sleep
tapes got me through my two week corona
fever sleep was hard to come by and i
was living in the strange in-between
world but every day i would put my
blanket and pillow out in the garden and
put sleep tapes in my ear and drift into
a peaceful sleep with the breeze on my
face and your voice soothing my tired
brain it's been a wild year for bridges
but as the man waxed ever so poetically
back in his march 2021 update post life
is brief and beautiful love is all
around us and available at all times
[Music]